going fast well they worked out they put  on their makeup  they wiggled back into their costumes  and finally they have an  audience ready and waiting once again  hello everyone this is johnny with the  cast and crew of mystere and we are  happy to say intermission  is over  [Applause]  yay after more than a year of closures  mystere returned to the stage in front  of a packed house  at treasure island last night this is  new video of that performance  the cast of mystere will hit the stage  twice friday nights through  tuesdays it's the first cirque du soleil  show to return to the strip following  the pandemic and boy did they have a  wonderful audience reception next up  oh we'll jump back into their pool at  the bellagio on thursday  michael jackson won and the beatles love  shows both return to the stage in august  caw at mgm returns in the fall  so good to see john so many people ready  for those shows